sobre todo
las personas que vinieron en la segunda
vuelta Como por ejemplo la compañera
Simone que fue de un gran apoyo
nuestra compañera eliciane nuestra
querida senadora del estado de marañón
nosotros aquí son todos marineros todos
los otros son
Marineros del primer viaje
yo quisiera comenzar
esta pequeña presentación que voy a leer
con un agradecimiento a Dios
Porque
yo toda la vida
que Dios siempre fue muy generoso
conmigo para permitir que yo saliera de
donde yo salí para llegar hasta donde yo
llegué y sobre todo en este momento en
que nosotros no estamos enfrentando un
adversario
no no estamos enfrentándonos a un
candidato sino a una máquina del Estado
brasileño
que está puesta a servicio del candidato
de turno para intentar evitar que
nosotros ganamos las elecciones Y
gracias al pueblo al pueblo brasileño a
quien yo Quiero agradecer de corazón el
pueblo que votó por mí
el pueblo que votó por el adversario que
llegó a las urnas que quiso cumplir con
su compromiso
de ciudadano Yo quiero darles mi
felicitaciones sobre todo
Quiero felicitar también
a las personas que votaron por mí porque
porque yo
me considero
un
ciudadano que pasó por un período de
resurrección en la política brasileña
Porque intentaron enterrarme vivo y
estoy aquí
[Aplausos]
para
estoy aquí para gobernar este país
en una situación muy difícil pero tengo
fe en Dios que con la ayuda del pueblo
nosotros vamos a encontrar una salida
para que este país vuelva a vivir
democráticamente armoniosamente
que nosotros podamos restablecer la paz
entre las familias y entre los
divergentes para que nosotros podamos
construir un mundo que nosotros
necesitamos y un Brasil Quiero agradecer
a mi compañero Fernando Adán mi gran
amigo
[Aplausos]
que hizo una campaña extraordinaria
Ana Estela su esposa
y también nuestra compañera Marina Silva
[Aplausos]
intelectual para parecer ahora
intelectual me voy a poner mis lentes
llegamos páginas para leer llegamos al
final de una de las más importantes
elecciones de nuestra historia
una elección que puso cara a cara dos
proyectos Opuestos de país
y que hoy
Tiene un gran ganador el pueblo
brasileño
no es una conquista mía ni del partido
de los trabajadores ni de los partidos
que me apoyaron en esta campana
una conquista de un inmenso movimiento
democrático
que se formó por encima de los partidos
políticos de los intereses personales de
las ideologías para que la democracia
saliera ganando
este 30 de octubre histórico la mayoría
del pueblo brasileño dejó bien claro que
desea más y no menos democracia
desde jamás y no menos inclusión social
y oportunidades para todos
y no menos respeto y entendimiento entre
los brasileños
en resumen desea más libertad
fraternidad en nuestro país
brasileño demostró hoy que desea más que
solamente escoger a quien va a gobernar
sus vidas
quiere participar activamente de las
decisiones del gobierno
el pueblo brasileño demostró hoy que
desea más que derechos Ah derecho para
protestar
insuficiente que no hay empleos que no
tiene un sueldo digno para vivir que no
tiene acceso a salud y educación que le
falta un techo para vivir y crear a sus
hijos con seguridad y que no hay ninguna
perspectiva el pueblo brasileño quiere
vivir bien quiere comer bien vivir vivir
Quiero un empleo un salario justo
reajustado siempre con el tema de la
inflación quiere tener Salud Educación
políticas públicas y calidad
quiere libertad religiosa
quiere libros en vez de armas quiere ir
al teatro ver al ir al cine y ver las
películas y los bienes culturales porque
la cultura alimenta nuestra alma el
pueblo brasileño quiere tomar de nuevo
la esperanza y es así como yo veo la
democracia no solamente como una palabra
bonita que se escribe en la ley sino
como algo palpable tangible que sentimos
en la piel y que podemos construir todos
los días Esa fue la democracia
en el sentido más amplio del término que
el pueblo brasileño mostró hoy en las
urnas fue con esta democracia real
concreta que nosotros asumimos el
compromiso a lo largo de toda nuestra
campaña y es a esa democracia que
nosotros vamos a buscar queremos
construirla acá Todos los días en
nuestro gobierno con crecimiento
económico distribuido entre toda la
población porque es de esta manera que
debe funcionar la economía como un
instrumento para mejorar la vida de
todos y no solamente para perpetuar las
desigualdades
la rueda de la economía va a volver a
girar
con generación
de los salarios y con la negociación de
las deudas que Perdieron su poder activo
la rueda de la economía va a volver a
girarse por los pueblos haciendo
formando parte de la inversión con apoyo
a Pequeños y medios productores que son
responsables del 70% de los alimentos
que llegan a nuestras mesas
con todos los objetivos posibles a los
micros y pequeños empresarios para que
puedan poner su extraordinario potencial
creativo ponerlo al Servicio del
desarrollo del país es necesario ir más
allá fortalecer las políticas para
combatir violencia contra las mujeres y
garantizar que ellas ganen el mismo
sueldo que los hombres ganan en el
ejercicio de la misma función
[Aplausos]
enfrentarse entreguas enfrentarse sin
tregua el racismo el prejuicio
la discriminación para que los blancos y
negros y los indígenas tengan los mismos
derechos y las mismas oportunidades
solo de esta manera seremos capaces de
construir un país de todos un Brasil
igualitario cuya prioridad sean las
personas que más necesitan un Brasil con
Paz democracia y oportunidades mis
amigos y mis amigas A partir de primero
de enero de 2023 voy a gobernar para 215
millones de brasileños y brasileños y no
solamente para los que votaron por mí no
existen dos Brasil somos un único país
un único pueblo una gran nación
no me interesa alguien
viviendo una familia nadie quiere vivir
en una familia donde reina la discordia
es hora de unir de nuevo a las familias
establecer Los lazos que rompieron
el odio
nadie quiere vivir en un país dividido
en permanente estado de guerra
este país necesita de paz y de Unión
este pueblo ya no quiere más pelear este
pueblo está cansado de ver al otro como
un enemigo y
tener miedo de ser destruido ya no
tenemos que bajar las armas que nunca
tenían que haber atacado y nosotros
escogimos la vida
[Aplausos]
el reto es muy grande es necesario
reconstruir este país con todas sus
dimensiones en la política en la
economía en la gestión pública en la
armonía institucional en las relaciones
internacionales y sobre todo en el
cuidado a los más vulnerables es
necesario reconstruir el alma de este
país
recuperar la generosidad la solidaridad
el respeto a las diferencias y el amor
al
prójimota regresar la alegría de ser
brasileños y el orgullo que siempre
tuvimos del verde amarillo y de la
bandera de nuestro país ese verde y
amarillo que no pertenecen a nadie sino
al pueblo brasileño
no a su compromiso más nuestro
compromiso más urgente es acabar con el
hambre otra vez no podemos aceptar como
no podemos aceptar esto como algo normal
que millones de hombres niños y mujeres
de este país no tengan que comer o que
consuma menos calorías y proteínas que
las necesarias
productor mundial de alimentos y el
primero de proteína animal si tenemos
tecnología
Y muchísimas tierras para agricultura si
podemos exportar a todo el mundo tenemos
el deber de garantizar que todos los
brasileños puedan tomar el desayuno
almorzar y cenar todos los días Este
va a ser de nuevo
mi compromiso número uno en mi gobierno
no podemos aceptar no podemos aceptar
como algo normal que familias enteras
sean obligadas a dormir en la calle
expuestas al frío a la lluvia y a la
violencia por eso vamos a retomar el mi
a casa de la vida con prioridad para
todas las familias de bajos ingresos y
regresar
programas que retiraron 36 millones de
brasileños de la pobreza Brasil ya no
puede más convivir con este en inmenso
fondo
se reconocen este país tiene que
reconocerse tiene que reencontrarse
consigo hombres además de combatir la
extrema pobreza y el hambre Vamos a
restablecer el diálogo en este país
es necesario retomar el diálogo con El
poder legislativo judicial sin intentos
de intervenir cortar
sino buscando reconstruir la armonía
entre las tres poderes la normalidad
democrática está consagrada en la
Constitución
etcétera la que establece los derechos y
las obligaciones de cada uno de los
poderes de cada institución de las
fuerzas armadas y de cada uno de
nosotros la Constitución rige nuestra
existencia colectiva y nadie
absolutamente nadie está por encima de
ella nadie tiene el derecho de ignorarla
o de hacerle frente además es más que
urgente retomar el diálogo entre el
pueblo y el gobierno es por eso que
nosotros vamos a regresar a las
conferencias nacionales para que los
interesados escojan su prioridades y
presenten al gobierno sugerencias de
políticas públicas para cada área
educación salud seguridad derecho de la
mujer
igualdad racial habitación y muchas
otras vamos a retomar el diálogo
gobernadores y los alcaldes para que
decidamos juntos las obras de prioridad
para cada una de las poblacionales
no interesa A qué partido pertenecen el
gobernador y el alcalde Siempre vamos a
querer el bienestar de la población de
cada estado de cada municipio de este
país también vamos a restablecer el
diálogo entre el gobierno entre los
trabajadores y la sociedad civil
organizada con el regreso del Consejo de
desarrollo económico y social
es decir
las grandes decisiones políticas que
tienen impacto en la vida de 215
millones de brasileños no van a ser
tomadas en confidencialidad a mediado de
la noche sino después de un aflo diálogo
con la sociedad
Considero que los principales problemas
de Brasil del mundo del ser humano se
pueden resolver con el diálogo y no con
la Fuerza bruta que nadie dude de la
fuerza de la palabra cuando se trata de
buscar el entendimiento y el bien común
mis amigos y mis amigas
en mis viajes internacionales y en los
contactos que he mantenido con líderes
de diversos países lo que más disfruto
siempre es que el mundo es extraña a
Brasil
extrañan aquel Brasil soberano que
hablaba de igual para igual todos los
países más ricos y poderosos y que al
mismo tiempo contribuía y aportaba con
el desarrollo de los países más pobres
Brasil que apoyó el desarrollo de los
países africanos por medio de
cooperación inversión y transferencia de
tecnología que trabajó por la
integración de América Latina de América
del Sur y del Caribe que fortaleció
mercosur y ayudó a crear el g20 una
surselac y los brillos hoy en día
nosotros estamos diciéndole al mundo que
Brasil regresó de Brasil Es demasiado
grande para ser relegado a este triste
papel de aislado en el mundo
vamos a conquistar vamos a reconquistar
la credibilidad la previsibilidad y la
estabilidad del país para que los
inversores nacionales e internacionales
retomen la confianza en Brasil para
que dejen de ver a nuestro país como si
fuera una fuente de ingreso
Y que pasen hacer nuestros socios para
retomar el crecimiento económico con
inclusión social y sostenibilidad
medioambiental queremos un comercio
internacional queremos un comercio
internacional más justo retomar nuestras
alianzas con los Estados Unidos y la
Unión Europea y nuevas bases no nos
interesan acuerdos comerciales que
condenen en nuestro país a el Eterno
papel de exportador de commodities y
materias primas queremos la
industrializar a Brasil invertir en la
economía verde y digital apoyar la
creatividad de nuestros empresarios y
emprendedores queremos exportar también
inteligencia Y conocimiento
Vamos a luchar nuevamente por una nueva
gobernanza global con la inclusión de
más países en el Consejo de Seguridad de
la ONU y cierto
eliminando el derecho al veto que
perjudica algunas naciones estamos
listos para comprometernos de nuevo para
combatir el hambre y las desigualdades
en todo el mundo y en los esfuerzos para
promover la paz entre los pueblos
Brasil está preparado para retomar su
protagonismo en la lucha contra la
crisis climática protegiendo todo
nuestros biomas sobre todo la selva
amazónica y nuestro gobierno fue capaz
de reducir en 80% la deforestación de la
amazonía disminuir de forma considerable
la visión de gases que generan el
crecimiento global y ahora nosotros
vamos a luchar por la deforestación de
la amazonía
Brasil y el planeta
necesitan una amazonía viva
una un árbol en pie vale mucho más que
toneladas de madera extraída y
legalmente por lo que solamente Piensan
en la ganancia fácil a costas de la el
de la el deterioro de la vida en la
tierra el río limpio vale mucho más que
todo el oro que se puede extraer con con
El mercurio que puede que pone en riesgo
la vida humana y de los peces
Cuando un niño indígena muere por la
ganancia de los depredadores del medio
ambiente una parte de la humanidad
también muere
[Aplausos]
por eso que nosotros vamos a retomar el
monitoreo la vigilancia de la amazonía y
vamos a combatir cualquier actividad
ilegal sea minería
extracción de madera
y también ocupación
Asimismo vamos a promover el crecimiento
sostenible de las comunidades que
habitan la región amazónica vamos a
probar una vez más que es posible
generar riquezas sin destruir el medio
ambiente Estamos
abiertos a la cooperación internacional
para preservar la amazonía sea como
inversión O con investigaciones
científicas pero siempre con el
liderazgo de Brasil sin jamás renunciar
a nuestra soberanía
tenemos compromiso con los pueblos
indígenas con los otros pueblos de la
amazonía Y con toda la biodiver nosotros
queremos la pacificación ambiental no
nos interesa una guerra por el medio
ambiente sino que estamos preparados
para defender el medio ambiente de
cualquier amenaza mis amigos y mis
amigas
el nuevo Brasil que nosotros queremos
construir desde el primero de enero no
quiere es no es importante Nada más para
el pueblo brasileño sino para todas las
personas que trabajan por la paz la
solidaridad y la fraternidad en
cualquier parte del mundo
el último miércoles el Papa Francisco
envió un importante mensaje a Brasil
orando y pidiendo que el pueblo
brasileño se salga del odio de la
intolerancia y de la violencia
quiero decir que deseamos lo mismo y que
vamos a trabajar sin descanso por un
Brasil donde a prevalezca el amor sobre
el odio la verdad venza la mentira y la
esperanza sea mayor que el miedo
[Aplausos]
todos los días todos los días de mi vida
yo recuerdo
a la mayor lección de Jesucristo que es
el amor al prójimo
Por eso creo que la virtud más grande de
un buen gobernante será siempre el amor
por su país y por su pueblo
en lo que dependa de mí de nosotros No
faltará amor en este país vamos a cuidar
con mucho cariño de Brasil y del pueblo
brasileño vamos a vivir un nuevo tiempo
de paz amor y esperanza
[Aplausos]
el tiempo en el que el pueblo brasileño
tenga derecho de nuevo a soñar y las
oportunidades para realizar todo lo que
sueña
para ello invito a cada brasileño y a
cada brasileña
independientemente de qué candidato de
Por qué candidato votó más que nunca
vamos juntos por Brasil
viendo lo que nos une y dejando de lado
nuestras diferencias
sé la magnitud de la visión que me ha
reservado el universo sé que no lo podrá
hacer solo voy a necesitar de todos
ustedes de todos los partidos políticos
los trabajadores empresarios
parlamentarios gobernadores alcaldes
gente de todas las religiones
brasileños y brasileñas que sueñan con
un Brasil más desarrollado más justo y
más fraterno
vuelvo a decir lo que dije durante toda
la campaña lo que nunca fue una simple
Promesa de candidato sino una
una promesa de vida un compromiso de
vida Brasil tiene solución
minutos vamos a ser capaces de construir
un Brasil del tamaño de nuestros sueños
con oportunidades para transformarla en
una realidad una vez más digo renuevo mi
eterna gratitud al pueblo brasileño
Quiero agradecer al compañero algo me
dice presidente
a los gobernadores que fueron elegidos y
los compañeros que no pudieron elegir
absoluta nuestra lucha no comienza y no
termina con una lección nuestra lucha
por la conquista de un país justo un
país en el que todos los brasileños
puedan comer trabajar estudiar
Siempre será una lucha que vamos a tener
hasta el final de nuestros días y me
caso de decir
no es el número de años que una persona
tiene y que eso es lo que envejece a la
persona lo que envejece a una persona Es
la falta de causa la falta de motivación
para la lucha Y es por eso que yo tomé
la determinación Brasil es mi causa el
pueblo es mi causa
y combatir la miseria es la razón por la
que voy a vivir hasta el fin de mi vida
[Aplausos]
un gran abrazo y que Dios bendiga
nuestra jornada a partir del primero de
enero
[Aplausos]
gracias
a Dios Y gracias a los medios de
comunicación por el trato que nos dieron
en este proceso electoral un abrazo de
corazón compañeros
[Aplausos]